欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,上一节我们已经讲了怎么样去判断市场潜力, 选对增量市场, 选对行业
这一节课我们来到下一个维度, 刚才选择了这个行业维度以后
我们要进去分析产品的偏好和款式风格属性等等这些功能
我们刚才从行业里面进去就看得到商机分析, 商机分析里面会有一个产品榜单
产品榜单里面有人气榜, 还有飙升榜, 蓝海, 还有效果榜, 这些榜单, 我们都可以去看这些产品, 看看这个类目里面, 哪些产品效果很好, 哪些产品当前非常受市场欢迎, 那么我们是不是就可以从这些维度, 去选择一些产品去发产品, 或者是说去推广一些相似的产品, 这边就是一个关键值的榜单, 也就是这些类目里面,
都是通过哪些词 来搜索的, 来搜索的, 如果你这里有数据, 我们就可以来这里参考, 获取这些关键词, 组合标题, 按照这个去发产品, 推广产品, 那么这个就是我们刚刚选的一个以行业来选, 选择了之后就选择, 栏装的绘度, 时间的话我们选择的是近30天, 行业里面选了市场之后, 再到一个商机分析, 商机分析之后就到买家分析, 买家分析之后,
然后再到卖家分析, 接下来我们来去看一下买家分析, 当我们确定了一级类目, 二级类目之后, 我们要选择买家数大的三级类目的产品优先切入, 去发产品和推广产品, 也就是我们一级, 二级都确定了这些类目了, 三级类目里面, 我们一定要去判断, 按照这些产品, 买家数比较多的这些品类去发产品, 和去推广这一类产品,
我们店铺的流量就会更加大一点
通过买家分析里面
第一个维度就是寻盘买家
第二个维度就是交易买家
因为通过分析这个类目下
哪个品类买家数更多, 流量更大
我们就知道具体要做哪些
比如说我点击搜索寻盘买家的时候
这边出现的国家是这些
当我选择交易买家的时候
这边出现的国家可能就是
另外的国家
那么我们可以选择这两个维度的国家的交集来进行作为我们的主要推广的国家
我们看一下我们要发产品发什么类型的产品呢
你看一下这个交易偏好比如说它的一个NOQ的偏好是什么中低这些维度
当然这些维度中低我们并不知道是多少数据
但是我们可以参考同行的一些爆品, 或者是说做的比较好的同行的一些产品的一个起定量
当然这个起定量也是在我们能够接受的范围内, 才会去参考和使用的
那么样品这些也可以参考一下, 第一是偏好这些店铺, 我们主要做什么类型的店铺
第四个就是定制偏好, 我们的店铺是做定制的还是做非定制的, 这些都可以参考
这里的数据呢,其实,参考的价值不是很大, 因为这些数据都是比较模糊的, 所以说我们重点参考的数据是什么呢, 重点参考的数据是这些国家住的数据, 以及这边的这些类目的数据, 也就是这些买家数占比大小, 你要去选择前面这些买家数占比大的这些类目, 先切入去做, 就更加容易获得流量了, 这次就是关于我们在三级类目的时候, 要选择第一个数据,
通过这两个维度去选择我们的类目再加上我们主要做的国家市场就ok了主要是这个是第一这是第二可以不怎么参考都行接着我们来看一下这个卖家分析要明确店铺增长的空间和同行的现状这就是知道自己的增长空间有多少以及同行当前的现状是怎么样的这些都要了解清楚那么明确整个行业店铺层级的分布以及这个行业的定位
行业的天花板数据在什么范围, 比如说我们点击刚才进入到卖家分析, 这个类目下, 一定是这个类目下, 同行, 店铺, 星等级分布, 也就是你看做这个类目的星级分布是怎么样的, 0星, 1星, 2星, 3到 5星, 这些维度的占比是多少, 那么3到5星, 你看他的占比是非常少的, 也就是商家占比是非常少的, 但是呢他的流量占比应该能够达到80%,
80%, 也就是少部分的商家的总的流量, 整个平台的总流量就占了80%左右, 通过这个评估当前自己店铺所处的位置, 星级越高, 流量资源分配越多, 所以我们想办法提升我们的星级, 如果你在零星的话, 说明你是所有商家48%里面都是在零星, 所以你星级越高, 那么跟你竞争的人就会越少, 这个维度的话就是判断总寻盘的
电话板, 比如说, 我们的店铺, 在这个类目下, 那么500个, 询盘以下的, 占了很多, 那么2000个以上的, 占了15%的商家, 在2000个, 询盘以下, 那么这个就可以明确的, 知道自己店铺, 询盘的, 增长空间了, 比如说你去看, 数据盖栏的时候, 你就要去看你的数据, 你的前, 询盘, 或者月, 询盘, 在多少范围呢, 比如说你一年, 如果按2000来算, 那么2000来算, 那么2000来算, 那么2000来算,
除以12个月, 你就得到每个月的一个寻盘量, 那么你就看看自己当前店铺, 整个月的寻盘量在多少, 离这个差距有多远, 那么你就知道, 自己整个店铺的寻盘, 还有没有增长空间, 如果你已经跟这个一样了, 那么说明你的空间是比较小的了, 如果你的差距非常的大, 那么说明你还有很大的空间提升, 那么最后面的这个就是年持收GNV, 了解当前,
行业的同行店铺的交易额大小, 判断自己交易能力的范围, 你看这里有分层了, 你看如果一个店铺在200万美金以上的占比非常小, 也就是商家数量非常的少, 不同的行业交易额占比是不一样的, 也就是我们现在看到的这个数据, 如果你换个行业, 那么他的交易额占比就是不一样的, 有的行业很大, 有的行业交易额极少, 所以我们来自己判断一下,
这个就能够看出整个行业它的整体一个交易的大小
如果你的目标定在了300万美金,那么很有可能达不成
为什么呢?因为这个行业里面的头部店铺都是在200万以上
那么它的量是非常少的
这些商家是非常少的
当然这里面只是部分的线上数据
因为还有很多商家他有很多交易数据
它是在线下成交的, 是吧? 另外的, 就是关于你的同行, 他发的最多的类目, 是哪些类目, 那么我们就从这里可以看到, 他们优先发的是, 男士, 卫宜和, 冒商, 以及男士, 必需, 他们主要在这两个类目, 发了很多产品, 我们在选择发产品的时候, 也可以先参考这个去发, 因为这些可能就比较容易来流量了, 这边的产品类型分析的话, 其实也没必要参考太多,
因为这些所有的行业大概都是这样的一个分布的逻辑
那么这个参考的价值就不是很大
那么这个板块就是通过查行业来进行分析的
我们到后台来看一下具体怎么样去操作
首先我们打开之后查行业就像我们刚才一样查行业找到类目
比如说我想做这个南装这个类目我点击它
点击它之后进来之后是不是就会有商机分析
就可以看得到我们想要的那些产品
就跟我们刚才讲的一样, 这边是词, 再到接下来就是买家分析这里面就有一些寻盘买家, 还有一个是交易买家, 我们只要选择不同的维度, 那么它这个板块的数据跟这个板块的数据, 以及下面的这些板块的数据都在变化, 这些数据都在变化, 所以说我们主要是选择寻盘买家, 去看一下重点看什么, 重点看这个地域, 这是我们主要的主推的一些国家, 以及我们要选择的这些类目,
买家占比数多的这些优先考虑, 最后就点击交易买家, 交易买家也是, 你看这里也是不一样, 我们优先考虑可能考虑这两个, 因为它买家数占比很大, 同时这些国家, 你看一下, 这两个类目占比大, 说明这些国家, 它也是偏向于这些国家里面去成交的, 在这些国家里面去成交, 最后一个就是卖家分析, 你看我刚才讲了这个, 新级, 你的竞争对手的新级分布,
以及整个店铺的整个询盘量啊, 一年大概是多少, 那么一年除以十二个月, 那么每个月大概多少
那么这个板块就决定了你店铺线上交易额大概多少, 落在哪个范围
如果你店铺里面落在这个范围, 说明你的店铺交易额是非常大的, 这里仅仅代表的是线上交易, 有很多是线下交易的, 他没有搬到线上
最后关于这个类目的, 你看他们同行在发什么产品切入, 都是前面这几个
后面这个就不用参考了, 这个就是关于整个查行业的数据维度进来, 选择内幕, 再选择对应的一个产品, 再选择买家, 再分析一下卖家, 就可以了, 这里我讲一个比较直观的逻辑, 比如说我的第一个圈是行业维度, 这是行业维度, 接下来里面的这个圈就是产品维度, 这是产品, 里面产品, 加上里面还有买家, 是吧,
买家, 里面还有, 我们的, 商家, 商家, 你看, 买家, 商家, 产品, 这三个维度在, 这个, 行业, 这个, 类目里面, 最终我们要实现, 这个, 产品, 体配, 买家, 这边是, 卖家, 重新写一下, 卖家, 到, 产品, 给到, 给到, 买家, 所以, 这个, 板块的话, 我们就可以, 非常直观的, 先通过, 行业, 了解, 产品, 产品了之后, 我们要, 知道, 我们, 同行, 的, 一些情况,
买家又是什么样的, 我们知道了卖家跟买家之后, 我们就想办法让产品跟买家更加匹配, 买家更加匹配就可以了, 我们最主要就是去找到这个产品, 然后匹配上相应的卖家就可以了, 这个就是关于查行业, 去选择内幕, 选择目标国家, 选择产品来进行运营我们的店铺, 能够更加快速精准的切入, 提升我们整个店铺的流量,
那么这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课我们再见